[Musique]
un bon soir mardi 6 octobre bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 c'est
l'essentiel de l'actualité locale en
quelques minutes voici les titres de
cette édition protocole sanitaire
clients qui peine à revenir depuis le
déconfinement les restaurateurs doivent
s'adapter face au co vie 19 mai la
profession évolue aussi dans
l'incertitude de l'évolution de cette
épidémie et des restrictions qui peuvent
être prononcées par le gouvernement
témoignages et invité françois bellini
premier vice président de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie versailles
yvelines
c'est un projet dans les cartons depuis
2013 mais lancer concrètement cette
année un datacenter est en cours de
construction à aubergenville ce centre
qui stockent les données des grandes
entreprises se veut nouvelle génération
il consommera 30 % d'énergie en moins
par rapport aux autres sites du genre et
puis retour sur alimentaire yvelines au
programme le week-end dernier à la
bergerie de rambouillet un rendez vous
dans le cadre d'un festival qui se tient
un partout en france pour sensibiliser
aux enjeux agricoles et alimentaires
à suivre également la suite de notre
dossier de la rédaction consacrée aux
mères dans le département
[Musique]
la question est sur toutes les lèvres
des restaurateurs allons nous bientôt
devoir fermer l inquiétude se fait
sentir dans la profession est aussi dans
les yvelines classé pour rappel en zone
alerte au coronavirus entre baisse de la
clientèle perte d'exploitation et moral
au plus bas
la crise sanitaire et prouve le secteur
reportage d'eléonore sinoquet et
d'astrid bergère à juziers et voisins le
bretonneux
depuis les amants sont arrivés une
semaine puis quand même bien plus légère
en termes de réservations ils sont
inquiets pendu aux lèvres du
gouvernement sur de possibles nouvelles
mesures liées à la crise sanitaire les
restaurateurs des yvelines ne savent pas
vraiment à quoi s'attendre
un tant soit peu rassurés du maintien de
l'ouverture de leurs voisins de paris et
de la petite couronne la grande couronne
n'en reste pas moins aux aguets c'est le
cas à voisins le bretonneux
le nouveau protocole ne nous concerne
pas pour l'instant directement
il y à des risques qu'un jour ça
descendre jusqu'à nous donc l'attrait un
petit peu plus compliqué il a un petit
peu plus contraignant
ce qui m'inquiète le plus entre nous
c'est que on a un métier normalement de
convialité d'accueil de chaleur et
qu'aujourd'hui on met beaucoup de
distance et ça c'est un petit peu un
crève coeur pour nous restaurateurs car
c'est un lieu de rassemblement des
changes normalement à juziers dans le
nord des yvelines en plus de la crainte
de la fermeture c'est aussi la perte de
clientèle qui préoccupent les
professionnels de la restauration on
leur impose déjà pas mal de protocoles
et si en plus il ya encore et encore et
encore d'autres protocoles à mettre en
place
je pense que les gens finiront par plus
sortir du tout quoi
à l'heure actuelle le couple ne veut pas
perdre espoir et continue d'assurer le
service
cette garder le contact avec les clients
qui nous restent et qui sont courageux a
toujours sortir à avoir nous soutenir
parce que la plupart qui viennent ils
sont quand même dit dans une démarche de
soutien
un soutien que le couple de
restaurateurs de jausiers aimerait aussi
obtenir de la part de leur assureur ils
ont rejoint le collectif resto ensemble
pour demander un dédommagement pour la
perte d'exploitation durant le
confinement
environ 90 milles euros encore un autre
sujet d'inquiétude
et pour parler de ses inquiétudes
françois bélisle est avec nous bonsoir
bonsoir par visioconférence premier vice
président de la chambre de commerce et
versailles yvelines cci qui est un rôle
et d'identification de ces entreprises
en difficulté aussi d'information et
d'accompagnement auprès de ces sociétés
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler dans un
instant déjà la crise sanitaire qui
s'est muée on ne sait en crise
économique a fragilisé on le sait les
entreprises est ce que du point de vue
de la restauration
beaucoup d'établissements ont dû mettre
la clé sous la porte dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui il faut éclairer les
restaurants le tourisme passent en
général a été lourdement sinistrés la
situation est pourtant bien entendre une
attitude complète de l'extension des eig
sanitaires
c'est dans dix villes à ce stade pour
très clair nous n'avons pas de fermeture
de grande ampleur pourrait donc c'est
éveil de l'état les aides de l'état ont
été j traces qu'il faut il faut l'avouer
a donc à la fois le péché fonds
solidarité fait que les entreprises ont
été aidées dans le cadre d'une toxine en
eau libre et variées mais j'ai comme ils
disent les parents c'est en fait
l'ensemble des charges doit supporter
les restaurateurs et les pieds des
causes même si le petit espoir de de
récupération chiffre d'affaires 6 ans
cet été que le on était tous positifs
des compliments arriver l'état était
sourd ou en là mais cela pour attraper
le chiffre d'affaires est aujourd'hui la
lanceuse et c'est le chiffre d'affaires
au niveau des jeux pc juste vous aide il
paie juin c'est le prêt garanti par
l'état qui effectivement l'une des êtres
qui a été débloqué donc on avons fait
face vous l'avez dit a pas de fermeture
grande ampleur mais on se retrouve quand
même avec un secteur assez fragilisée
dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui il faut savoir
insiste aussi cet angle on dirait le
l'outil mot classe mme chan de commerce
pour faire des études puis pourtant les
restaurateurs envisagent dé 40/100 et
les restaurateurs n'osent pas ce qu'ils
vont faire mais seulement donc énorme au
niveau des fermetures éventuelles des
120 heures en grèce pour ses quartiers
aux têtes c'est tout s'est créé beaucoup
d'incertitude on l'a compris alors le
gouvernement a fait des dernières
annonces à paris et dans la petite
couronne ces zones passe en zone d'
alerte maximale et restaurants restent
ouverts mais avec un protocole très
strict et les bas restent fermés vont
être fermées pendant deux semaines au
moins les yvelines ne sont pas pour le
moment concernés par ces nouvelles
restrictions mais difficile d'imaginer
que si l'épidémie continue de progresser
de telles mesures ne soient pas prises
dans le département est ce que du coup
les annonces d'hier elles ont été plutôt
rassurante pour vous plutôt inquiétant
puisqu'il ya quand même cette fermeture
des bars même si les restaurants restent
ouverts dans un sentiment est très
visitée du a réellement préoccupé par
ces règles étaient renforcées mais par
contre on concentre aujourd'hui les il y
avait comme un touché on sent que les
fermes eu un impact direct et donc non
mais si ça il ya de charge
et puis 1 1 allez faites don rip les
fermiers est une minute françois bellini
mais il est important de dire quand même
que dans cette crise la cci est aussi un
rôle à jouer avec de l'accompagnement de
l'identification d'un rôle d'information
aussi de ces entreprises la cci est
auprès de ses restaurateurs aussi de ces
entrepreneurs qui sont aujourd'hui dans
l'incertitude
et si le genre phonique centralise les
au niveau de l'île de france mais tous
les 6,6 de français et d'allemand ce
type de cellule
les deux noms des entreprises et on a eu
l'emprise des aides à des prêts de
trésorerie qui s'est dit ou deux sur la
vérité aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui
2010 le pôle ans le double ambition
relais ariani l'horizon de la
technologie là pour ça qu'ils doté d'un
budget 100 milliards d'euros et ses
repères des entreprises même s'il était
heureux aujourd'hui
non loin d'elle la série il avoue qu'il
y ait des rapports
merci françois bellini pour toute
question et je vous invite si vous êtes
restaurateur entrepreneurs à joindre
directement la chambre de commerce
et d'industrie de versailles yvelines et
je rappelle un françois béni merci
d'avoir été avec nous vous êtes le
premier vice-président de cette cci
versailles yvelines
[Musique]
une nouvelle sénatrice dans les yvelines
thuan bourg à 51 ans a pris ses
fonctions officiellement jeudi dernier
la mer les républicains de saint rémy le
nori remplace alain schmitz l'ancien
président du conseil général des
yvelines a démissionné de son poste
réélu dès le premier tour en mars
dernier dans sa commune thuan bora doit
quitter son fauteuil de maire par
conséquent la loi lui empêche de cumuler
les deux étiquettes
une première pierre symbolique pour le
thésée datacenter à aubergenville elle a
été posée vendredi en présence des
différents acteurs du dossier le premier
bâtiment de ce centre de stockage de
données elle doit être effectif dès
l'année prochaine les précisions de
bixente n'a rien senti steban à un
campus de six bâtiments hébergeur de
données
c'est la promesse d'une these datacenter
d'aubergenville un projet élaboré depuis
2013 qui sera complètement
opérationnelle en 2028 la construction a
démarré en février 2020 cette année bien
sûr on a été arrêté à cause de la crise
du coc vide il sera opérationnel au
deuxième trimestre 2021 nous aurons cinq
autres bâtiments donc au total six
bâtiments pour une puissance totale de
18 mégawatts sur ce campus
d'aubergenville pour absorber une telle
quantité de données
le projet repose sur de la très haute
technologie afin de réduire les coûts
des entreprises engagées l'approchent
principal de tata senteurs qu'on appelle
un data center de nouvelle génération
c'est à la fois d'avoir un niveau de
sécurité disponibles est très important
mais en même temps une empreinte
environnementale très amélioré notre
datacenter consommera 30 % d'énergie en
moins par des technologies que nous
avons mis en oeuvre de free cooling par
exemple mais également de l'intelligence
artificielle comme nous utilisons pour
optimiser des rendements de
de nos équipements un campus 100%
français soutenu par le département des
yvelines et la commune d'aubergenville
aujourd'hui la grande majorité des
hébergeurs sont des hébergeurs anglo
saxons et nous sommes nous avons créé ce
projet afin d'apporter une réponse
française avec la souveraineté des
données pour aubergenville ce projet
data center c'est la promesse
d'industrie d'avenir sur le territoire
nous sommes chez nous et les données
françaises restent en france et ça c'est
un sujet très important pour le devenir
et la sécurité de nous donner un futur
centre qui coûtera au total plus de 10
millions d'euros auprès duquel six
entreprises se sont déjà engagés elle la
suit à présent de notre dossier de la
rédaction consacré cette semaine aux
mères dans le département des yvelines
pour ce deuxième numéro rencontre avec
lionel vast après un mandat dans
l'opposition il est aujourd'hui à la
tête de la municipalité dans brésil est
le seul maire sig les écologistes sur le
territoire yvelinois son portrait signé
mélanie poké marie pas neutre à nikola
d'android
il ya du monde à des opérations
nettoyage ce samedi 3 octobre à andrésy
chaque année avec berges de seine les
habitants ramasse des déchets parmi les
nettoyeurs le maire de la commune
lionel vast c'est bien évidemment des
valeurs qu'on m'a inculqué dans ma
famille et c'est aussi depuis longtemps
une grande passion pour la biodiversité
pour la flore et ensuite je suis devenu
apiculteur amateur et quand on est impie
culteurs on est tout d'un coup
extrêmement sensible à la biodiversité
tout d'abord engagés dans des
associations lionel vast se lance dans
la politique en 2014
élue d'opposition il gagna le siège de
maire lors du scrutin de 2020 il ya un
besoin du sculptural
des spectacles de marionnettes on avait
fait un gros travail lorsque nous étions
dans l'opposition municipale nous avions
mieux compris certaines problématiques
de la ville certains dossiers de la
ville et de la même façon que lorsque
j'étais dans les associations pour
réussir finalement à concrétiser nos
projets et bien il fallait la la ville
on s'est fait connaître progressivement
on a les andrésiens eu confiance
progressivement et en moi et en mon
équipe et et puis ça a fonctionné
le maire délaisse parfois son écharpe
tricolore pour retrouver ses élèves il
devient professeur de sciences
économiques et sociales il enseigne
depuis 20 ans dans un lycée de conflans
sainte honorine
ce qui me tient à coeur c'est garder un
pied dans mon métier c'est en fait le
seul moment où je ne pense pas à ma vie
où je ne penserai au courrier d'un
andrésiens que je viens de recevoir
voilà ça me libère le cerveau je vois
d'autres personnes et en plus j'ai la
chance de danser nue une matière qui
plaît aux lycéens
elles libérées de six heures
d'enseignement par semaine lionel vast
est aujourd'hui le seul maire écologiste
du département des yvelines jusqu'en
2026 sa majorité j'avoue une commune de
près de 15000 habitants est le sport et
les jeux olympiques de 2024 dont vous le
savez plusieurs épreuves se tiendront
dans les yvelines le comité
d'organisation a révélé hier les 145
centre de préparation pour les athlètes
ils pourront s'y entraîner en vue de
l'échéance et ces sites sont dans les
yvelines le parc jean carillon aux
clayes sous bois par exemple qui servira
de piste d'essai pour le bmx est le
gymnase paul mallet attrape aussi pour
la gymnastique artistique la ville de
versailles accueille elle trois centres
de préparation pour le hockey sur gazon
l'équitation et le pentathlon les
athlètes pourront y venir dès l'été 2021
et ce jusqu'à l'été 2024
le 14e festival alimenterre se tiendra
lui du 15 octobre au 30 novembre partout
en france cette opération vise à
réfléchir sur notre manière de consommer
aussi sur nos systèmes alimentaires à
rambouillet le week-end dernier
la bergerie nationale i a participé en
lançant alimentaire d'yveline célia gars
de son go et nicolas d'ombrie du pain du
yaourt et de l'eau c'est leur pack ont
pu préparer les enfants qui sont venus
cet après midi à la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet on a fait passer pour les
poules et les poches
et puis pour touré pour le mapping du
par l'agglo il ya des activités qui
aiment un peu un peu ludique pédagogique
puis ça change chaque année là il y
avait un atelier cuisine c'est un peu
plus qu'une ferme
beaucoup d'activités ont été faites pour
les enfants comme une animation ils
apprennent à cuisiner leur goûter ou des
ateliers de soins aux animaux pour les
sensibiliser au monde de l'agriculture
c'est l'occasion pour eux de devoir un
petit peu la nature les animaux comment
prend soin d'eux comment on les nourrit
voilà les voir ailleurs en vrai plutôt
que dans un livre où ils connaissent les
noms mais de les voir en vrai c'est une
autre expérience
l'objectif d'alimentaire divine est de
présenter aux visiteurs des circuits
courts et mettre en avant les
producteurs et les activités de la ferme
la chance qu'on a c'est de pouvoir
rencontrer directement directement le
producteur de pouvoir savoir exactement
ce qu'on va mettre dans son assiette
on se rend compte que finalement le
produit n'est n'est pas forcément
beaucoup plus cher parce qu'il y avait
du coup moins d'intermédiaires et du
coup le consommateur achète directement
et on sait que l'argent va dans la poche
directement du
du producteur et justement il y avait de
nombreux producteurs des yvelines comme
la biscuiterie de la vallée de chevreuse
l'idée c'est surtout d'être proche des
consommateurs c'est à dire que pour moi
c'est important de venir à leur
rencontre de les écouter
j'ai moi j'ai pas de catalogue de
présentation de produits je ne marche
qu'à la dégustation et il y avait de
tout sur les étals produits laitiers
terrine chocolat ou encore de la bière
prochain rendez-vous à la bergerie
nationale le 21 octobre avec une
nocturne une soirée lampions frissons et
dégustation et puis cette grande
reconstitution historique elle se tenait
le week-end dernier au château de
breteuil à choisel organisée en
collaboration avec quatre associations
l'événement proposait un voyage au
travers des époques du 12e siècle
jusqu'à la seconde guerre mondiale et
dans les couloirs du temps nicolas
d'andry des templiers à l'entraînement
des moments de prière une reconstitution
de la vie de ces moines soldats au 12e
siècle pour faire découvrir l'histoire
aux visiteurs du château de breteuil
l'objectif de l'association la flamme
boussad le premier rôle du templier
c'est de protéger l'accès aux lieux
saints postérieurement la première
croisade ça c'est vraiment la toute
première mission du temple mais
évidemment il ya clairement une
connotation religieuse derrière la
création de l'ordre du temple est
d'ailleurs le temple est rattachée non
pas au royaume de jérusalem ni aucun
royaume mais directement au pape
donc là on a une tenue de chevalier
david maison donc constitué d'une robe
logiquement de ce qu'on appelle le
mental blanc qui est spécifique aux
chevaliers et puis on a également des
sergents qui ont pour particularité eux
de porter le manteau noir dans ce voyage
à travers le temps château de breteuil
des jacobites écossais du xviiie siècle
les soldats utiliser plusieurs armes
face aux anglais de la charge à la dup
l'association sarralbe agro constitue la
culture historique de l'ecosse
et jacobites ce sont les fidèles des
stuart qui étaient des anciens régnant
sur le royaume d'angleterre et décosse
qui était catholique et qui se sont
retrouvé éjecté du trône par les
protestants certains jacobites écossais
et irlandais se sont réfugiés en france
et ont croisé la route de la famille de
breteuil d'ailleurs une de nos ancêtres
leurs rob ryan était une irlandaise
jacobites elle a épousé claude charles
de breteuil en 1720 et nous avons son
portrait dans le château voilà petit
clin d'oeil via les jacobites donc aux
ancêtres de la famille grenadiers
napoléonien soldats américains ont
accompagné ce plongeon dans l'histoire
le temps d'un après midi au château de
breteuil
et dans un instant ne manquait pas un
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture c'est tous
les mardis à 18 heures 30 et s'est
présentée par justine brasier ces images
pour refermer ce journal pour vous dire
que l'automne est bien là comme vous
pouvez le voir sur ces arbres en vallée
de chevreuse pas de feuille encore à
terme et une belle coloration rouge a
observé une saison automnale qui se
ressent aussi dans les températures qui
ont baissé depuis quelques jours voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée à tous sur
tv 78
[Musique]